إنه لأمر مزعج
للغاية مشاهدة هذا الفيديو ورؤية قادتنا
بما في
ذلك نائب الرئيس آنذاك مايك بنس وهو يركض للنجاة
بحياتهم هنا هو في
لقطات أمنية مايك بنس
وعائلته هناك وهو
ينظر إلى الوراء وهو
يتم اصطحابه إلى خارج العاصمة حيث
كان  كان
ملتزمًا بواجباته الدستورية
المتمثلة في عد الأصوات الانتخابية
التي تمت مرافقتها
حتى لا يقتله وهو
ما قال الغوغاء الضخمون
أنهم أرادوا قتله
ودانا التي كنت تتحدث عنها قبل دقيقة.
الفيديو عن الضابط يوجين جودمان
أحد
أبطال ذلك اليوم أه وكيف أن
كبار مساعديه في الثمانية من رومني لم
يعرفوا حتى
أنه كان ضابط شرطة العاصمة
الذي نقل رومني إلى بر الأمان ، فلنشغل
هذا الفيديو هنا هو
أه رأس المال هناك هذا الضابط غودمان
أعتقد أنه يجري
هناك وهناك ميت رومني هناك
يركض آه
مرعب للغاية نتحدث نتحدث
عن دان  نتحدث
عما فعلته الجماهير
لو ذهبوا إلى مايك بنس ،
فماذا كانوا سيفعلون لو
حصلوا على ميت رومني السناتور ميت
رومني ،
إنهم لا يستحقون هذا ، لا ، إنهم لا
يستحقون هذا والحقيقة  أن هناك
أعضاء جمهوريين في مجلس
الشيوخ لن يحاسبوا الرئيس ،
والبعض منهم في الواقع
يخضع للمساءلة هو أمر محير تمامًا